body cameras have become a common tool
used by law enforcement across the
United States and the footage they
capture is often instrumental in
investigating crimes and allegations of
police misconduct but one security
researcher says that many models
currently in use by police departments
are vulnerable to a wide range of
digital attacks we can track it we can
manipulate the data on it upload and
download videos like white videos and
the cameras could even be used to
smuggle malware into a police station
worst case scenario launching an attack
like that would be probably a ransomware
attack against evidence storage
repository Josh Mitchell the security
researcher who discovered these issues
and body cameras says the devices suffer
from many of the same security lapses
found in other connected Internet of
Things products like baby monitors and
printers and even cars hold on yeah I
think altogether this whole setup for
less than two dollars
Mitchell who works in San Antonio Texas
showed me how he can hack into one
camera at the vive you le five lights
video feed using a laptop and a
long-range antenna he bought online if
you were doing an attack out in the
world there'd be like a million devices
all connected to different networks so I
can identify this specific device based
on the wireless access points I walked a
few dozen yards away wearing one of the
cameras and Mitchell easily hacked into
it he could see everything where I went
and even the passcode I used to lock my
phone alright so you walk down there get
out your phone entering one two one two
five six or something like that one
three or five six but that's just the
beginning
many of the cameras can connect
wirelessly with other devices and they
transmit a unique ID as part of the
process but none of the Wi-Fi enabled
cameras Mitchell analyzed masked those
signals essentially turning them into
tracking beacons these cameras were
designed for transparency not not safety
or security really Mitchell says the
signals broadcast by the devices could
compromise law enforcement safety or
help bad actors evade officers they
don't try to hide themselves right but
but for a bad guy
you know sometimes police officers need
to be able to hide themselves right
that's why you have unmarked police cars
and in addition to being able to track
and stream from various devices
Mitchell found ways to remotely access
footage stored on four of the five
models he studied using that kind of
hack an attacker could download modify
delete or even replace video files I
wore one model the fire cam on call
around town as we got lunch when we got
back to Mitchell's home office I used a
web browser on my phone to review the
footage I'd taken on the camera but in
the next room Mitchell was also looking
at the files on his laptop I'm going to
use a program that I've written to list
all the media files on the device I will
download one of the media files and then
I will replace it with something else so
we're gonna see what he does and I
should be able to see it change in real
time on my display my footage was gone
in its place an old wired video so it's
stealthy the file name is the same but
instead of footage from lunch or from
the ice cream shop
it's a wired video and finally it's not
just footage that's vulnerable Mitchell
says some of the devices could even be
used as digital Trojan horses to
introduce malware into a police station
if an attacker was so inclined depending
on the model you could upload malicious
software to these devices that then
launches attack against the PC that it's
connected to you know if you wanted to
delete all all evidence stored you could
do that Mitchell is presenting his
findings that this year's Def Con
security conference in Las Vegas he's
alerted the body camera manufacturers
about their vulnerabilities and has
suggested fixes here's what they need to
do randomize the MAC addresses and the
Wi-Fi access point names and information
that's something smartphones now do to
hide individual users Mitchell says the
cameras should also have better access
controls and integrity checks to ensure
the footage they capture is authentic so
I know exactly what device which
Media file came from and that it hasn't
been tampered with
wired contacted the manufacturers of all
the cameras Mitchell studied by view
which is now owned by axon said they are
fixing the vulnerabilities he identified
patrol I said they are aware of his
research and are evaluating it fire cam
says it discontinued and no longer
supports the on call model although new
units are still being sold by third
parties digital Ally and CSC didn't
respond to multiple calls and emails by
deadline Mitchell says it's unacceptable
that these issues in the cameras make it
possible to tamper with evidence and
could be put in suspects investigations
and law enforcement personnel at risk
digital evidence from these cameras are
being used to to prosecute people and
with such high stakes Mitchell says the
fixes can't come soon enough
[Music]